James is in Wisconsin
my wife is applying for the economic
injury disaster relief loan she claims
it does not have to be paid back why is
it not called a grant thank you because
it is not a grant it is alone with
promises of forgiveness if you meet the
stipulations you remember that time that
they said if you take out a student loan
and you work for an underprivileged
under underserved area for ten years
that they would forgive your student
loans and then they didn't you remember
that I remember it I remember it clearly
and these loans they don't even have the
ink is not even dry on the legislation
the banks don't even have the notes
figured out they don't have that but the
documentation figured out they're
slapping this stuff out there and it's
going to cause you trouble listen if
something sounds too good to be true let
me help you
it is and when the federal government
says we're here to help those should be
the scariest words you ever hear in your
life so not a chance that we're going to
recommend you take out the PPP loan or
the eid our loans either none of them if
they are forgiven effectively they're a
grant but I am predicting a mess on the
forgiveness and I am predicting this
some of you are about to walk up into a
noose that you thought this was just
like a hot knife through butter free
money from the government let me just
tell you there's no such thing so Ken
one time I was doing rehabs on houses
really you were actually with the nail
no I was this back for once broke I had
like four crews and I got over into one
of the gentrified areas of Nashville
East Nashville where they were doing
historic rehabs now this is before her
doing historic rehabs over there was
cool now now everybody's over there done
but I mean I got these 1908 houses and
this kind of stuff and they were pieces
of junk and but they were very ornate
you know beautiful woodwork
and mantels and stuff in them and so I
get this one house and the hysteric
Commission I mean the historic
Commission has grants for $5,000 if you
keep the facade of the front of it
looking historic because they want to
put the homes back into their natural
and their cute beautiful little homes
and so it made sense to do it from an
aesthetic viewpoint and I thought I'm
doing this anyway I might as well get
the five thousand dollar grant and so I
get all signed up I'm counting on this
five thousand dollars which I wasn't
spending what about thirty thousand on
the property to fix it up so the five
thousand you know it's a pretty big
chunk back percentage-wise
well codes comes out and says I your
front porch doesn't have a rail around
it and I said why no it didn't have a
rail around it in 1908 and the historic
Commission wants me to put it back to
meet 1908 guidelines yeah well you can't
get a use and occupancy permit nobody
can live in the house we don't put a
rail around the front porch and I called
the story Commission they said if you
put a rail around the front porch you'll
get the $5,000 yes to government
agencies working together to like a hand
yes in a brick yeah to put you in a
corner yeah exactly right you know what
I did I put that I put the rail on the
front porch I got the you know and I
tore the rail off and then I got the
five thousand dollars so I had to beat
them at their own game but there's
innovation you know that's just you know
but good god that's great disobedience
is staring like the historic Commission
in come in in contrast with the
Nashville codes look and you know that's
exactly what the craps gonna happen here
with these things look like this is
exactly it sounds like free money cats
yeah well that's true well listen this
isn't a political stay but a rail around
it this is a statement of fact they
didn't let anybody read the bill okay
there are people like you and I that pay
attention to the facts and the facts are
that when they passed the stimulus
package there was no review of the bill
there's all kinds of stuff in there that
the bankers don't even know I've talked
to some friends of mine because I want
to get rid of that story they can't even
get the funds I know they're they can't
get the funds
and they can't get well they're not
gonna get the tech in the loan ya
O'Connell said it today they need
another stimulus package so this thing
can get the guidelines the regulations
aren't in place you're about to get
screwed America it's a loan I'm sorry I
know you were stimulated but you
shouldn't have been I'm just telling you
you shouldn't have been you can't put
the rail around it oh you could put the
rail around it no you can't put the rail
around it nope it's not gonna be
forgiven it is gonna be forgiven I mean
did you hire those people back where
they're the kind of people we wanted you
to hire back are you abiding by all our
politically correct guidelines did you
make a donation to Planned Parenthood I
don't know what are they gonna dream up
I don't know and I'm not being a
conspiracy theorist I just know the
borrower's slave to the lender and baby
use a slave